le château van der bilt est à carrières
sous poissy depuis 1885 2000 mètres
carrés de bâtiments williams qui sam van
der bilt un homme d'affaires et éleveur
de chevaux américains achètent la
propriété en 1906 pour sa proximité avec
paris et la normandie
un manoir légèrement surélevé pour voir
l'hippodrome aujourd'hui disparu il a
bâti j'irai son empire équestre ici et
fait donc de l'élevage de chevaux
sa spécialité pendant un peu plus d'une
quinzaine d'années voilà donc des riches
propriétaires se sont succédé et à la
sortie de la 2ème guerre mondiale il ya
un premier abandon de ce lieu puis donc
les sablières moderne en fait ici et
exploite donc le sable les granulats on
ont fait leur siège social voilà ils
vont aussi exploiter les terres
attenantes au château le site connaît un
nouvel abandon dans les années 90
squatter puis rachetée par la
collectivité le site a connu une
réhabilitation par les usines éphémère
qui récupère des lieux en déshérence
depuis 1987
dans cette pièce dans laquelle nous
sommes donc l'atrium plutôt bien arrêtée
de plutôt bien préservés quoi de
boiseries sont d'origine avec quelques
graffitis bon voilà ça a été retravaillé
repeint pensée etc
et il ya eu en fait c'était assez
rapides et sûrs un an et demi de travaux
donc c'est vraiment rapide et un million
deux je crois de budget pour 2010 mètres
carrés s'est ramassé au prix du mètre
carré c'est pas énorme
le château van der bilt devient le
château éphémère géré par van der lab
fabrique sonore et numérique en novembre
2014 un lieu de création artistique avec
trois studios de répétition et un
d'enregistrement met à disposition un
atelier de travail on met à disposition
des outils donc ça peut être des
systèmes de sonorisation des lumières
des vidéo projecteurs évidemment le
soutien donc humain puisque voilà il ya
une équipe au château on est six
personnes et de cette équipe
ben voilà on connecte l'artiste soit la
ville la cité soit évidemment à d'autres
acteurs culturels donc d'autres lieux
des endroits d'exposition de monstration
voilà tout un réseau professionnel qu'on
peut aussi à mettre en connexion avec un
artiste résident lieu de la bid oui de
la réflexion le fab lab voit naître de
nombreuses créations établi machines à
coudre et imprimantes 3d permettent de
faire naître les inspirations
artistiques ont fabriqué des objets donc
on peut réaliser ses rêves
certaines venir voilà donc on va
prototype et certains objets on rend
accessible du coût des machines outils
ou des outils numériques au grand public
voilà on est dans une démarche de
vulgarisation de cette culture
scientifique et 2
toutes ces démarches artistes en herbe
ou public amateur le château éphémère
propose aussi des ateliers le 9 mars
prochain les familles pourront créer des
têtes d'animaux en volume